I do in a newly released portion of a taped
deposition former president Donald Trump did
this I declined to answer the question I declined
to answer the question same answer same answer
same answer same answer same answer same answer
more than 400 times Trump pleaded the fifth to
a rapid-fire line of questioning coming from
the New York attorney general Leticia James's
office part of her civil investigation into
the Trump organization's business practices the
deposition a rare window into how Trump acted
under oath anyone in my position not taking the
Fifth Amendment would be a fool an absolute fool
and a major reversal from what he once argued
in public on the campaign Trail and as president
you see the mob takes a fit if you're innocent
why are you taking the Fifth Amendment
in the August deposition Trump used his opening
remarks to lash out at the attorney general who
is sitting in the room with him claiming the probe
was political and repeating one of his familiar
phrases this is the greatest Witch Hunt in the
history of our country and criticizing how James
campaigned for her office it's important that
everyone understand that the days of Donald Trump
are coming to an end promising to bring Trump
to Justice we cannot permit a renegade and out
of control prosecutor to use this investigation
as a means of advancing her political career all
claims James denies the contentious sit down took
place just two days after the FBI searched Trump's
Mar-A-Lago home for classified documents one month
later claiming you have money that you do not have
does not amount to the art of the deal it's the
art of the steel James announced her office's
250 million dollar civil lawsuit against
Trump three of his children and the Trump
organization accusing them of manipulating
the value of properties to make more money
many questions directed to the former president
during the deposition focused on financials you
reviewed this document with Alan weisselberg and
your son Don Trump Jr before it was finalized
as part of the 2019 statement of financial
condition is that correct same answer Trump
continued to plead the fifth when asked about
the company's former CFO Alan weiselberg who
is now serving time after making a plea deal
with the Manhattan District Attorney's Office
in a separate case Mr weiselberg do you have
plans to return to Trump work when you're done
a case that found the Trump organization guilty
on 17 criminal counts including tax fraud
and the Trump organization denies the allegations
made by the aeg's office including those against
the Trump family and Company Executives this case
is expected to go to trial in October Aaron Trump
and his attorneys have tried to delay that start
so far they have been unsuccessful all right Brian
of course that timing puts you right ahead of uh
the beginning of the primary season thank you and
Ryan Goodman joins me along with John Dean both
out front so Ryan we know that Trump obviously has
previously given his opinion of people who plead
the fifth right that this is for uh something the
mob does right you only do it if you're guilty
but just taking aside his point of view from a
legal perspective right he went in there chose to
do this under legal counsel what does it tell you
that he chose to invoke at more than 400 times
so I think it means he's in trouble legally at
least in the civil case if you're in a criminal
case and he pleads the Firth that can't be used
against him but in a civil case there's plenty of
New York state law and around the country they can
absolutely in fact the jury will probably see
the same videotape in full each time somebody
uh try to play that because as we were joking
if we played all 400 everybody that would have
still taken several minutes yeah that's right
so they could make 400 adverse inferences in
a certain sense uh meaning that they can say
because he took the fifth it is a suggestion
of wrongdoing and the American public can make
the same inference themselves in law you can do
it in a civil suit and we could do it ourselves
to think of it that way and it's interesting that
he himself said you know anybody in my position
would be a fool and absolute fool for not taking
the fifth well his uh son Don Jr and Ivanka Trump
according to CNN's reporting within the two weeks
before his deposition they were deposed they
didn't take the fifth right so and he did and
as you say it's crucial that it can be used as
evidence in the civil case so John let me play
some more uh video from the Trump deposition as
Ryan's pointing out that the Federal grand jury
will see this is just after Trump stated he would
be taking the fifth throughout the deposition so
he announces this and then this happens so
Mr Trump I take it you are are not going to
answer any questions about your preparation
today with your council is that correct
and then should I say this or should
I respond to that just read that
for all of the reasons provided in my answer
which is Incorporated herein in its entirety
I declined to answer the question that was the
first time and then of course there were about 400
after that John you say his decision to do this
to invoke the fifth in this way is unprecedented
absolutely I I certainly know uh Nixon gave a
number of depositions post-presidency and I've
looked around uh to see if he did and there's
no indication he ever gave a fifth amendment uh
invocation uh he didn't do so when he was before
a grand jury still looking at Watergate after
he'd left the office and I can't find Aaron
any president who ever has invoked the Fifth
Amendment so this is unprecedented wow which
is amazing and Ryan it's just as you point out
shows he's could possibly be in real trouble to
do that because it can be used against him uh but
there's the other legal issues and I'm not even
talking about the January 6 in the Federal grand
jury in Georgia and all of those issues how
about just basically the grand jury that was
just convened in Manhattan to begin presenting
evidence in a case related to Trump's role in
hush payments uh to Stormy Daniels the adult film
star this case seemed to be going nowhere and now
suddenly you've got the D.A bringing Witnesses
and you've got a grand jury what does that mean
so it sounds like they're very serious um you
don't bring a grand jury unless you're seriously
considering criminal charges and New York has a
special rule for the statute of limitations that
otherwise people might have thought would have
run by now due to covid so so it got a yet an
extra you gotta You Gotta Buy you gotta yeah and
everybody did in a certain sense all their cases
so I think that's very serious and it does mean
that uh the district attorney might be mounting
a criminal case now it has to be a pretty
sophisticated case because the charge for
falsifying his business records for hush money
payment would be a misdemeanor they have to tie
it to another crime but that might be like a New
York state election law crime and that's what
the focus will be on so all of this mounting just
as people were thinking perhaps it was only only
the Federal grand jury in January 6th then Georgia
all of these things as well John I want to ask you
about what's going on with President Biden and the
classified documents though as well because we're
now reporting that the FBI searched President
Biden's think tank in November after his legal
team told the National Archives that they found
classified documents there but we didn't find out
about it then and in fact it was months before
we learned the classified documents were found
in that office uh we may never would have found
out about them being in his home if journalists
hadn't reported that right it wasn't team wasn't
the White House nobody else put this information
out if this is just so simple and there's no there
there why is there why is it so complicated why
is nobody putting the truth out there uh it
does it look like there's something to hide
well that's the impression they're giving with the
mishandling of the communications of what is going
on uh it's surprising that as sophisticated as the
Biden uh operation is that they don't recognize
you've got to get the truth out get it out fast
and get it out in full because that's the sort of
Impressions we get that they're hiding something
we know this was a voluntary uh invitation for
the FBI to come in and do the search uh apparently
they we don't know what they found or didn't find
but it is not good for the Biden people to have
these kind of stories constantly drip drip drip
right and they do it's constantly drip drip drip
thank you both very much John Dean Ryan Goodman